we talked about this a little bit
yesterday with the NFL adding 24
full-time officials and what does that
mean and how long before everybody is a
full-time official and is this a
precursor to gambling legalized gambling
where the league says to its betters we
have full-time officials I don't know
how a full-time official is better than
the part-time officials what do you do
in the offseason is it more just the
perception than reality of this so
that's why we wanted to talk to Dean
Blandino Dean used to be the former NFL
senior VP of officiating now working for
Fox Sports NFL rules analyst Dean thanks
for joining us what do you make of this
24 full-time officials what does that
mean to you yeah well you know to me
it's a it's the start of what's already
been a long process this is five years
in the making going back to the the
negotiations in 2012 during the lockout
and the league has been pushing for
full-time officials and we've been
working with the Union to try to make it
happen I think this year it's going to
be a it's going to be a year of figuring
out where to best utilize these
full-time officials and and I know that
the NFL needs more access to their
officials there they're going to get it
and but I'm not sure how much it's going
to move the needle in terms of accuracy
on the field at least initially I think
you're going to see some some benefit
and communication and and consistency
and that's the goal because now with
these 24 full-time officials or up to 24
it'll be it'll be easier to to
disseminate that information amongst the
entire staff and get everybody on the
same page what's the downside to this of
having just twenty four full-time
officials and the other you know notable
officials like you know Ed Hochuli or
part-time officials yeah that's a good
question something that that well I was
part of those discussions and so you
have a subset of your entire staff
that's full-time and our team is going
to to say well you know we we want the
full-time officials we don't want the
part-time officials and we had our
full-time officials three games and you
and our division opponent had them sick
so I think there is going to be some
some of that that we're going to have to
it through and see how it goes and and
look full-time officials part-time
officials they're going to make mistakes
it happens the game is fast and nobody's
perfect and so I don't think anybody
should expect that this is going to you
know create perfection in officiating
but I think from a communication
standpoint it can help this is the this
is what I see happening initially Dean
and that is if a full-time official
makes a glaring mistake you know what
does that say about the full-time
officials or if it's a part-time
official and he makes a glaring mistake
well would he have made the mistake if
he's a full-time official it just feels
like there's a PR nightmare that that is
sort of hanging in the balance here can
you sense that as well yeah I can't
sense that and look we can't we can't
get around the fact that that part of
this is it's about PR part of this is is
you while you're you've got full-time
coaches full-time players everyone else
is full-time and your officials who who
effect games and the decisions that they
make are part-time so there's no
question that there's a PR element to it
I don't think it's just PR I think
there's more there's more to it I think
there is some true benefit but we are
going to see some things like that where
full-time official makes a mistake and
now and now we're now we're dealing with
that fallout so it's going to be
interesting to see how it plays out I
think that we've just made the job too
tough for them of just calling the game
is one thing now did you complete the
act now you have to decide how long
somebody celebrated you know what's a
football move here it didn't used to be
this way being is it should we be asking
officials to monitor how long somebody
celebrates and whether or not you're
going to throw a flag on that yeah I
agree with that we've always try to take
the approach of simplifying the rules
for the officials because it has become
so complicated and if you go back and
watch and I try to go back and look at
old games and look at it from an
officiating perspective and there was a
call and it was made and we moved on and
we didn't break it down and we didn't
analyze it eight different ways and and
and the world continued to spin on its
axis but it seems like
this is this is become and maybe not
just in football officiating but we're
in this world of social media and
technology and everything is just
completely over analysed and it is it is
a extremely hard job to do and the
expectation is perfection and then
that's not possible but I almost think
instant replay works against the NFL
whereas in other sports it may not hurt
it as much but we get to see everything
we get the benefit of it and social
media it's the most popular sport and it
feels if you took away replay I wonder
how we would view officials yeah that's
a good point and we've had those
discussions replay has really it's it's
been a benefit and then we're never
going back right because I remember a
world without replay and that's that's
not a great world in terms of
officiating but it has it has really
shined a spotlight on officiating more
so than ever before and and it just
creates this this world of scrutiny that
that they're under currently your job
now and Fox NFL rules analyst is this
similar to Mike Pereira's job yes this
will be similar I'll be working closely
with Mike will be doing will be doing
both college and NFL games and being in
the studio and supporting the studio
staff and and the talent at the games
and then being added some games and
helping in that way so it'll be working
closely with Mike how concerned are you
about the guys you used to oversee being
upset at you that now you're
second-guessing them or critiquing them
sure that's that's definitely you know
talked to Mike a lot about that because
he went through it and I think there's a
way to critique and there's a way to
give your opinion but but do it in a
respectful way and certainly I'm going
to have an opinion and I'm going to be
I'm going to be commenting on it but but
from my background I know that I'm going
to do it in a respectful way and I think
the guys will the officials will will
respect that nervous now I'm excited I'm
excited it's a new challenge and excited
to be in this in this in this world and
just up for the challenge brief to the
point be succinct and just so we can
understand it less is less is better
less is more when you first start out
because everybody who gets in this
business keeps talking and yeah that's
what everybody keeps telling me yeah
yeah and coming from you that that's
that's good if I get to the point make
sure people understand it and don't
speak in the language of an official
speak so the fans understand it they can
consume it and then get the hell out of
the way that's would be my advice and
any any new rules that we need to be
aware of on the field this year anything
that's really yeah I think so the new
rules there wasn't a lot there wasn't a
lot of major changes but I think the
ones that we'll see come into play is
you know they eliminated eliminated the
jumping over the over the line on field
goal and extra point attempts so you
can't do that even if you don't make
contact we're going to see a you know
changes in replay where the referee is
going to use a tablet on the sidelines
versus going under the hood and and some
changes in terms of game game pace I
think that's another big thing that the
NFL is really working on in terms of
eliminating some of the in-game downtime
so I think you're going to see some more
efficiencies there good luck with it
Dean and you know don't be afraid to ask
for advice because everybody's asked for
it in this business
appreciate it and curse will call you
when you screw up okay thank you me
saving less you think all right the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience